the Joe Rogan experience as you write
more and more books do you find it to be
more and more difficult or do you find
it to be easier
well my early books were all focused on
trying to bring scientific ideas out to
the general public now the elegant
universe was about string theory about
the cosmos space and time hidden
realities about multiple universes and
so in that role I'm basically trying to
translate from the cutting-edge research
into ordinary human language so that
people who don't want to go to graduate
school can get the basic idea of what's
going on in this book is a very
different proposition I I feel like I've
moved in a significantly different
direction through this book because yes
there's science you know entropy
evolution the history of the universe
from the beginning to the end but the
focus on why we humans do what we do why
we tell stories the emergence of
language why we tell myths why we engage
in religious experience why creative
expression is so important to us this
felt like it was drawing upon things
I've been thinking about for decades but
never put into to writing so it was a
harder exercise than anything that I did
before because it was a different
exercise but in the end one that I felt
was even more gratifying because it was
making clear why these ideas matter as
opposed to just trying to tickle the
brain of the reader I'm trying to
actually if you will touch the heart and
soul of the reader and that's something
which if it's successful feels very
gratifying I would imagine that would be
very hard to end to feel how like to put
the cover on it and to go that's it yeah
right it is and I thought that's true
almost with with all books you know the
the famous adage is that you never
finish a book you abandon them that's
all that ever happens and that was true
in spades in this particular case
because the subject was so big you know
and you can always imagine going further
in this direction or enhancing that
description but at some point you
recognize that you know life is an
ongoing process and a book is ultimately
a snapshot of where the author was at
the moment that the book was written and
that to me is really what happens here
this is a
a snapshot of my view of the human
condition set against the cosmological
unfolding and how much of your
perceptions of these things has evolved
you know as an educator and as a
scientist and as a person who's in the
public eye how much how much of your
perceptions on these ideas have changed
over the course of your career
huge huge I think I was a very
hard-nosed science thinker when I
started I think part of this may have
been I became a professor at a
relatively young age I think it was 27
when I got my first faculty job so many
of the graduate students were the same
age as me so I think I felt the need to
have a very rigid scientific outlook on
the world peak because of that and you
know as I've gotten older that has
changed and my willingness to entertain
a broader range of thought and
experience and ways of being has
absolutely grown the other thing that's
had a vast and vital impact on me or
students you know for 30 years the only
thing I really taught was technical
physics courses quantum mechanics or
relativity you know thermodynamics and
what do you do there you're at the
blackboard you're putting equations up
there you're trying to get the kids to
be able to solve problems and understand
what the mathematics is all about so the
only thing you're really ever doing is
touching the cognitive part of their
brain for the last few years I've been
teaching a course the students didn't
know it that's actually based on this
book so I wanted to try out the ideas
with young minds so I've taught a course
at Columbia Laura jhin's and meaning and
in that course I had students from
across the campus not just the physics
students at the neuro students the
anthropology students the linguistic
students the theological you know so
there's a whole range of students and to
see how their understanding of how their
major or subject fits in to the
cosmological unfolding changed many of
their perspectives on what it is that
they're studying and what they're doing
and to have students come to my office
and to feel shooken up shaking up
whatever the right form of that verb is
where they're saying you know I've lived
my life in such
but now I'm gonna think about religion
as perhaps an evolutionarily interesting
and useful development as opposed to
something from on high or when I think
about creative expression as something
that might seed ingenuity and innovation
as opposed to something that is just
pure inspiration coming from the outer
world I'm thinking about my life
differently and some of them frankly
would be upset I've had students come in
tears and I'd never had that when I
teach quantum mechanics you know yeah
more than one more than one because
they'd say this course is kind of
shaking my sense of who I am and what I
am in the world what was the key aspect
of it that was shaking them well for
some students it was the it was the
notion of religion mm-hmm because many
of them or at least some of them had a
traditional religious upbringing and
their academic life and their religious
life were completely separate and now
when you have a course in which you're
focusing upon how it would be that this
institution of religion might naturally
evolve on planet Earth based upon what
we know about humans and human brains
and the evolutionary pressures that
we've been under some of them began to
think about religion as a very different
proposition than the one that they had
when they were growing up and I was in a
position that I'd never been before of
basically counseling of student and
saying hey it's okay to have your world
shake a little mint it's okay to think
about things you may come back to
exactly where you were before this
course but if a collection of ideas can
make you rethink your life the least
it'll cast it in a different light it
illuminated differently go with it see
what happens and I never had a
conversation like that when teaching
Schrodinger's equation you know and for
me is the most gratifying pedagogical
experience that I've ever had because
you're reaching the whole person as
opposed to just reaching this cognitive
technique of solving equations
[Applause]